[Music]
[Music]
something else
14 inches starting a new career
[Music]
yeah this is
and
really
cool
f harry
[Applause]
florida we are doing it what's up
i like that i got the laugh from the
florida they're shoes like yes florida
very funny
i've actually been spending my pandemic
down here in florida i did my quarantine
here which was pretty amazing because 50
of the people in florida believe in
covet and the other 50 will have you
spin their mouth to prove they're not
gay
she was wild out here
people in florida treated coven like it
was a tv show on netflix they just
binged it last march and then just
forgot about it
you'd be out and you bring it up like oh
that kovich it was crazy and they'd be
like oh i didn't watch that one i'm not
into sci-fi
they'd be like i watched tiger king
though that was pretty good
i wasn't planning on being down here for
the pandemic what happened was i came to
visit my parents and then covet happened
and now i'm retired so
[Applause]
yeah
it's going pretty great i'm gonna buy
some white new balances tomorrow
yeah i'm going to get into golf and
racism next you know
all the florida [ __ ]
what is it about being 100 years old
that makes you want to have velcro on
your shoes and to be able to use the
n-word freely
i'm asking for my dad's neighbor
those walls are very thin and i know
he's not listening to odb
so yeah he's into the clan just not the
wu-tang one
[Applause]
this dude has the biggest confederate
flag i've ever seen in my life hanging
off his porch it's insane like picture
car dealership big now double it right
i know and i know a lot of people say
that that flag's about the history but
that one definitely about the racism
i don't get the confederate flag maybe
it's because i grew up in new york but
it just doesn't make sense to me like
having a confederate flag is like having
photos of your ex-girlfriend up all over
your
apartment and then inviting your new
girlfriend over to your apartment
and being like oh these know it's
nothing weird it's just about our
history together
oh what do i want to do for fun i was
thinking maybe you could dress up as my
ex-girlfriend
we'd go back to our old apartment
reenact fights we used to have
for the history
what would we fight about slavery
what side was i on never mind i got to
go
get a tattoo removed
don't worry who dixie is
it's crazy i'm living in florida i'm
crashing with my parents right now 38
years old i'm crashing with my parents
it's [ __ ] up this was not the plan you
know
[ __ ] was going very well before the
pandemic for me i got on tv twice last
year i got judd apatow's email address
i'm sending him he's not answering but
don't worry
he's busy yeah
and now i'm crashing my parents at 38
years old the other day my dad asked me
if i had brushed my teeth
i want to be like [ __ ] i got
great pubes what are we doing here
you start knocking you're going to find
out real soon
this dude is not knocking or he's
knocking but he's doing the knock as he
opens the door
it's [ __ ]
yeah i feel like my dad is trying to
catch me jerking off
because he didn't catch me as a teenager
and i feel like he thinks that's
something we missed out on
did i brush my teeth no [ __ ] i'm
going to ride my bicycle leave me alone
yes i have my helmet shut up
oh man i'll tell you this i didn't think
i was going to be headed into my 40s
masturbating with headphones again but
here we are
it's real
i got one bose noise canceling headphone
on one ear i got one eye on the door
you know how hard it is to catch a nut
when you're in full panic mode
i'm just terrified my dad's gonna come
bursting in at any moment like you got a
new architectural digest
people
people say all the time too you're in
florida that must be so relaxing it's
like yeah if your idea of relaxing is my
dad trying to catch me jerking off every
20 minutes sure
and it's not even just the coming like
the other day it's seven in the morning
seven in the morning i'm asleep i i hear
thwack two o'clock
i'm like what the [ __ ] are we getting
invaded i roll over my dad's in my room
knee pad's on crowbar pulling up the
flooring
i'm like jimmy what are you doing he's
like buddy they're coming to replace the
rug three weeks we got to get this out
of here right now
i can't even get mad at him you know
what i mean because my dad just has that
dad brain my dad has a dad he can't turn
it off and the [ __ ] up part is too now
i have that braid too
like i i'm just wired that way that's
the craziest thing about living with
your parents at this age you get to see
the people who installed your character
defects
i'll just be sitting there at dinner and
i'll just be like oh [ __ ] that's why i
cry in the shower that's it right there
[Applause]
uh it's it's it's been insane i'm living
in an old folks community right now
i know or my mom will say this isn't an
old folks community this is not a 55
plus community and that's true because
there are three other people right now
who are living there who are also
crashing with their parents
and we see each other every day on our
walks and give each other knowing looks
like yeah we [ __ ] up we shouldn't have
followed our dreams
i should have took that bus driver's
test i could be in a union right now
yeah
this is totally true before kovit my
dream was to have my own television show
now it's just to be able to pick my own
television show
did you guys know that there are 376
shows that take place in alaska and my
dad watches every one of them
i've actually figured out how i'm going
to get my own tv show i'm just going to
move to alaska
yeah and i'm going to tell jokes to
bears and it's going to be called
alaska's got talent
[Applause]
oh man it's been wild too my parents got
the rona while i was down here it was
just crazy i know they're okay they're
good which is nice you guys don't care
you're like i don't know they sound kind
of shitty dude
[Music]
now they were great that was my favorite
part about my parents getting covered
they were okay actually my favorite part
about my parents getting coveted is the
fact that i know i didn't give my
parents covet
yeah yeah it's like that same feeling is
when you find out your ex is pregnant
and you know you're not the dad you're
like i didn't do that it wasn't me i'm
cool
yeah that is every man's biggest fear is
that he's gonna get his ex pregnant
like for every man no relationship is
actually over until 28 days after that
relationship
[Applause]
yeah for men a relationship is like a
sentence it's not over till the period
i got that same app on my phone
i'm not shocked my parents got the rhona
though mostly because of the fact that
my mom is way too friendly my mom is the
sweetest woman on earth like my mom
would open mouth kiss a stranger if they
asked her
nicely she'd be like they seem sad they
asked i don't know
and old people here in florida will walk
up to you without a mask because they're
all just ready to die
yeah they're like a biggie smalls album
yeah they're hoping for life after death
my parents were good about the mask
though i was really proud of him for
that that was
some people hated the mask i you know i
had no problem with them i'm a fan of
science
i like that
i like that i can free-ball this face to
the world now though don't get me wrong
i was actually on a hike a couple months
ago one of my friends and i was wearing
my mask and he was giving me [ __ ] about
it he was like why are you wearing that
mask right now dude there's nobody else
around and i was like i wear this mask
for the same reason i wear a condom
because i don't know who the [ __ ] was
there before me
yeah masks were like condoms for your
face like whenever i saw a do down
public not rocking a mask i just assumed
his dick was riddled with stds
yeah i imagine that dick looked like an
old banana you know
very spotty little yellow kind of
crooked
also by the way you know that dude who's
rocking a mask with his nose just
sticking over the top that's the dude
who asks hey can i put in just the tip
[Applause]
also by the way men the tip is the worst
part that's where the [ __ ] comes out of
stop asking to put that in
yeah like if a dude's like ladies if the
dude says hey can i put in just the tip
you'd be better off going hey how about
just the balls
because that's where they keep the [ __ ]
but nobody's getting pregnant you know
what i mean like you'd be better off
going in soft and sideways that's all
i'm trying to say
my friend too was giving me [ __ ] too he
was like i feel like you're wearing that
mask because you don't trust me and i
was like yeah [ __ ] i don't
he was like that's [ __ ] up why don't
you trust me and i was like dude you got
herpes from a stripper in dallas in your
30s
[Music]
like if that [ __ ] happened in your 20s i
understand people make mistakes and he
was like that's [ __ ] up you know i was
drunk and i was like [ __ ] i was
blacked out from 13 to 29 and my dick
still looks like it rolled off the
factory floor
that's not totally true
i got this one weird scar in the bottom
but we don't have time to get into that
tonight
yeah just know i was 13 i was wearing a
condom to the mall i was trying to be
ready at all times
yeah there was a manager for every 21 i
was very fond of
maybe today maybe today
i actually had to move twice during the
pandemic the first time i moved because
my girlfriend wanted a much nicer place
the second time i moved because my
girlfriend did not want me in that place
yeah i went through a little bit of a
cove breakup we did what's called a
conscious uncoupling do you guys know
what that is yeah that's when you break
up but you still have six months left on
that lease
yeah
and it's weird when you live with your
ex because when you live with your ex
you can't have sex you can't have sex
with anyone else and you can't leave
dishes in the sink so by weird i mean
it's exactly like still dating my ex
i should have seen that [ __ ] coming too
because when we first started dating she
said to me hey i think we should write
our names in all of our books in case we
break up
yeah i'm not an english professor but i
believe that's what they call
foreshadowing
and now i'm single for the first time in
a decade it's crazy 10 years i haven't
been single in 10 years
thank you
thank you i appreciate it thank you it's
wild like i was with this woman for six
years before that i was married for four
and a half years like the last time i
was single barack obama was in his first
term as president tinder hadn't been
invented yet and people weren't openly
talking about eating ass
yeah the times have changed he's 20 year
olds they're psychos they're out there
eating ass
[Applause]
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not doing it
call me old fashioned
i'll do anything but eat your ass
actually that's what i'm going to write
on my tinder profile i'll do anything
but in your else
i'll co-sign on a loan i got great
credit i got an a-10
yeah i don't know if you know [ __ ] about
credit scores that's a [ __ ] good one
i own a 2016 toyota prius paid for it in
cash with dick jokes i own a car i'm not
eating your [ __ ] [ __ ] off
this is totally true this is totally
true 20 year olds were actually eating
so much ass at the beginning of the
pandemic new york state governor andrew
cuomo had to send out an email telling
them to calm down on the eating ass
do you know how much ass you have to eat
to get the government involved
i imagine it's asked by the pounds i do
not know
20 i i mean 20 year olds you're gross
knock it off it's
disgusting i shouldn't talk [ __ ] though
i was the grossest 20 year old in the
world i think between the years of like
2001 and 2011 i brushed my teeth like
three times
i i know i might as well have been
eating ass my breath already tasted like
it
also 20 year old men irish spring that
is not soap that is the government
cheese of soap knock it off
get yourself something with an oatmeal
in it something that exfoliates you're
worth it
you know what i'm lying to you guys i
probably would hate s in my 20s
i probably wouldn't because i didn't
have any confidence in my 20s i didn't
really like myself that much in my 20s
that's why i drank a lot in my 20s and
alcohol the reason was alcohol will give
you confidence and i know that for a
fact because one time when i was drunk i
invited a woman back to my apartment
when i knew i didn't have electricity
yeah she came too or she didn't come but
she like showed up
you guys know what i mean
that's not even the most embarrassing
thing i ever did in my 20s this is
totally true one time while i was having
sex with a woman i said to her i can't
believe you're letting me do this right
now
[Applause]
i know have you ever seen someone
realize they made a mistake while you're
inside of them
i know
i don't know what the opposite of
getting wet is but i definitely did that
for her so that was kind of cool
[Applause]
i got to feel like a magician i was like
where once there was a river now there's
a desert
i actually said to da at the end it was
pretty [ __ ] up
i feel bad for people in their 20s their
20s is the hardest period in your life
nobody tells you that the 20s is the
roughest period in your life your 20s is
like a second puberty but instead of
getting hair in your balls you have to
learn how to pay your own vision and
dental it's [ __ ]
it's so hard like when you're in your
20s and you go through a breakup you're
like oh my god my life's over i don't
know what i'm going to do when you're in
your 30s and you go through a breakup
you're like oh my god i need a new
[ __ ] mattress
like when i was in my 20s and like i was
so poor and broke living in new york
city starting out in stand-up comedy my
room was so small i couldn't have a
regular sized bed in there i had to have
a bunk bed
yeah try being 26 and picking up a woman
with a bunk bed
she'd be like hey you want to go back to
your place and i'd have to be like hey
are you afraid of heights
and you can't have crazy wild sex in a
bunk bed that shit's not happening
there's only two positions sideways and
disappointed that's it
yeah like if a girl has to get on top
that means i'm underneath the bed
jerking off
i used to tell women too that i had a
loft bed but then they thought we were
going back to make love in my loft
apartment when the truth is they were
about to get side [ __ ] in what used to
be somebody's coat closet
also 20 year old dudes in here i want to
give you a piece of advice because i had
a hard time with women in my 20s and i
want to tell you this because i want a
woman to [ __ ] you more than once right
yeah because here's the thing if you're
a 20 year old man and you're in here
there is a device that you can buy that
you can keep in your bedroom that will
greatly increase the chances of a woman
having an orgasm and it will greatly
increase her chances of her coming back
to have sex with you again and it's a
very simple device you can get it
anywhere and it's called a bed frame
[Applause]
you hear that
those are some women who [ __ ] some
starving artists right there
get yourself get your [ __ ] mattress
off the floor no woman wants to be
[ __ ] a dude whose mattress is on the
floor look and i'm not even saying that
[ __ ] needs to be like west down get
[ __ ] four cinder blocks and a piece
of plywood
yeah
yeah
they'll be like he has goals he has
aspirations he has hopes
no woman wants to be banging a dude and
be reminded how close she is to her
bottom
both physically emotionally and mentally
i'm not even trying to [ __ ] anybody
right now
i'm sure i'm not i don't give a [ __ ]
right man i like you know what i mean
like in your 20s you're trying to find
i'm in my i don't care you know what i
mean like i'm not available right now
i'm not like and i'm not in a
relationship and i'm not single what
this is is happily alone
that's what i am right now yeah it's the
best
it's the best
like i like i know someone will [ __ ] me
in my 30s that's the difference like i
know someone will [ __ ] me now because i
have skills i bring [ __ ] to the table
you know what i mean like
i know how to roast a whole chicken
yeah i i own a la cressette that's
french cookware someone will [ __ ] me
20 year old men pick up skills buy
spices spices are the things that go in
cabinets cabinets are what i used to put
empty jack daniels bottles on top of
yeah because i thought that was art in
my 20s
i was like look at all i've accomplished
but now i'm not trying to [ __ ] any of
these people i could give a [ __ ] because
here's the thing i like me now i didn't
like me in my 20s so now if you want to
[ __ ] me you got to be cool you got to
like bring [ __ ] to the table like if you
want to [ __ ] me you got to have a 401k
because one of us is going to need it
[Laughter]
and also by the way i don't need anyone
to [ __ ] me now cause i can [ __ ] me
yeah
yeah and after i [ __ ] me i'm gonna watch
the movie i want to watch
yeah i'm never watching gilmore girls
again that shit's
over
i don't give a [ __ ] what's happening
stars hollow right now
i don't know what it is about my dick
but apparently it pairs very well with
gilmore girls
like if my dick was on netflix netflix
would be like you also might like the
gilmore girls
i don't want to make it sound like an
anti-relationship though i love
relationships i think our relationships
are amazing like the last relationship i
was in was incredible the woman was
great i
learned so much during that relationship
and i grew a lot during it and by that i
mean i got fat as [ __ ]
i got so fat in that relationship but i
feel like that's nature's way of telling
you you're in love you know what i mean
like nature's like ice cream donuts
you're not going anywhere buddy
like have you ever seen one of your
friends after they start dating somebody
new and you see them coming and you're
like oh [ __ ]
and they're like dude stephanie's
amazing i'm in love and you're like i
can tell you're rocking a 2x right now
i didn't know diabetes was a side effect
of love
happy for your heart worried for your
toes
my whole goal after my breakup is i just
wanted to become an internet thirst trap
you literally covered your mouth on that
it was great i know thank you
and and so far i've lost 37 pounds since
thank you
and so fun
and so far after shows two women have
slid into my dms
thanks
thank you i have not responded yet
i'm just way too nervous now that i
think the sex will be bad i'm just
afraid we'll pop my blow up mattress
there's actually a term for when you
have sex on a blow-up mattress it's
called dry docking
it's not because you're having sex
outside of a pool it's just because no
woman can get wet while getting [ __ ]
on top of a floatation device
should i have said whap do you think
that would have been funnier there if i
said well okay
everyone knows what whap is right or
whop depending on yeah yeah i guess yeah
i mean if bernie sanders knows who cardi
b is everyone's going to know who cardi
b is right
like if a bernie sanders at home with a
mitten stirring up pot of macaroni like
yeah it does kind of sound like [ __ ]
[Applause]
after the breakup i decided i was going
to come here to florida to see my
parents stay with my folks and i was
worried about corona so i was like i'm
going to camp the whole way that's what
i'm going to do i'm just not going to
stay in hotels and i don't know if you
guys can tell from my vibe so far i'm
not much of a camping guy
like i don't know [ __ ] about camping
like and like okay so how do i get into
this so
so i had to take a [ __ ] in our garbage
bag in the woods okay
and i was in albuquerque new mexico very
windy state not the state to be [ __ ]
in a garbage bag in the woods
gale force wins in albuquerque new
mexico
i picked a place called pack out which
literally means you have to take your
[ __ ] with you uh which i didn't know and
i was talking to my manly camper friend
about it he was like well what technique
did you use and it was like technique i
shot into a bag in the woods
and he was like yeah but you went
through the legs right i was like oh no
i went full skier and he was like full
skier i was like yeah you know full
skier
like
like you know when they're taking off at
the olympics that was me and i was going
for the bronze
[Applause]
and here's the thing i opened my car
door to try to block the wind but wind
can go under car doors
lifting garbage bags basically making me
look like a giant beaver [ __ ] in the
woods
let's put it this way i've now
officially been camping zero times i've
[ __ ] on my hand once
[Applause]
and it's weird when you [ __ ] on your
hands in the woods
i imagine it's a lot like when you bury
a body in the woods like
there's a lot of wet wipes involved and
you hope no one ever finds out about it
yeah
i got hotels the next two nights too
because i would rather get covet than
[ __ ] on my hands again
it's wild me me and the ex we were
[ __ ] serious man we were talking
about whether or not we wanted to get
married uh clearly not um
what what happened was her little
four-year-old niece just walked up to me
in disneyland in front of her whole
entire family and just went why won't
you marry my aunt
i know it's like hey kid shut the [ __ ]
up
[Applause]
i didn't actually say that i love her
she's the greatest
but i couldn't tell the truth you know i
couldn't be like well your aunt's been
married before and she's still working
through some [ __ ] spiritually so
pretty much it's on her at this point so
the truth it was scary because we had
both been married before so we both knew
how hard it was and we both knew how
much a [ __ ] wedding cost this is
totally true average cost of a wedding
in new york city where i'm originally
from sixty thousand dollars
yeah you guys know sixty thousand
dollars right like the amount of money i
made in my twenties if we round up by 37
000
60 000 this is why i feel like young
people shouldn't be allowed to get
married or not that young people
shouldn't be allowed to get married but
you should have to be married like five
years before you can throw yourself a
wedding because like young people don't
know what to do with money young people
like we'll be fine no people are like no
you won't
like if you ask any older couple who's
been married for more than five years if
they were throwing themselves a wedding
hey do you want to spend ten thousand
dollars on appetizers they'd be like you
can go to hell
[Applause]
because older couples know nobody gives
a [ __ ] about the appetizers at your
wedding like people only care about one
thing at a wedding and it's not your
love it's the open bar
[Applause]
you could have six kegs of beer and some
totino's pizza rolls and people still be
like this is a pretty good wedding
i also feel like you should i also feel
like you should have to go on your
honeymoon before you get married that's
something i believe i think you should
have to go on your honeymoon some people
say live together before you get married
i think honeymoon because if you can't
get along in hawaii you're sure [ __ ] not
gonna make it in cleveland
and also by the way no more destination
weddings i'm out i'm done i'm not
renewing my passport to watch you make a
mistake
and oh and also by the way if you do
have a destination wedding and you get
divorced in the first five years we're
all getting refunds now
and your fine
and you're flying us to your divorce and
you're having it somewhere fun like
acapulco
my idiot guido cousin
yeah and i
and i say guido in the meanest white
pasta
and if you don't know what a guido is
it's just a dude who's covered in
hundreds of tattoos of jesus bleeding
you'd be like hey sal what's the last
religious thing you did and he'll be
like what are you talking about i just
gave up fingering for len
all right peace be with you buddy
hey you're insane of meatballs that guy
on his scarface wedding he spent a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars yeah
hundred and eighty thousand hundred and
eighty thousand dollars to his bride
could feel like a princess for the day
went for a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars she could have became the actual
queen of detroit
very cheap property there
180 000 and i don't even remember that
much about that wedding isn't that crazy
i remember two things there were giant
marble staircases she had to walk down
before we could eat and there were piles
of cheese stacked up like blow
like so much cheese if anyone ate all
this cheese they wouldn't ship for three
years
isn't that crazy i went to a wedding
that cost as much as seven kia souls
[Applause]
all i remember stairs cheese that's it
that's [ __ ] up
like that's they spent 180 000 on a
wedding only thing they had to chauffeur
it at the end of that wedding was a
photo album of them spending a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars
once again this is why i feel like young
people shouldn't be allowed to get
married because if that was any older
couple if you gave any older couple the
option between you could have a photo
album to remember this day for the rest
of your life or you could afford a
stackable washer and dryer
yeah there's not an old car
there's not an old couple isn't like
give me the [ __ ] whirlpool baby
a mother of three would kick her own
pastor and the [ __ ] for in-unit laundry
but young people are like no we need
that photo album we need to remember
this day for the rest of our lives
[ __ ] i've been married i'm divorced
i got one of those photo albums i'm not
doing [ __ ] with it
but i know what i'm gonna do with it i'm
gonna photoshop my new girlfriend's face
on top of my ex-wife's face
yeah and then when i propose to her i'm
gonna give her that photo and be like
hey i just saved us ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
i got divorced i got divorced for the
main reason most people get divorced uh
i picked wrong
yeah
i went with opposites attract
yeah opposites also [ __ ] a bartender
named craig so
[Applause]
oh do you guys think i [ __ ] craig
i didn't [ __ ] crack i could have though
don't get weird about it i like to think
of craig's dick as like the iceberg on
the titanic it got me off the ship
[Applause]
also by the way if you're in here and
you're in your 20s and you're thinking
about getting married right now don't
[ __ ] do it
statistically people get married in
their 20s first people wait till their
30s don't make it like let's put it this
way if you bought an unframed poster in
the past decade you're not ready to be
married
[Applause]
you're not responsible enough to be part
of a joint checking account
[Applause]
this is totally true on my honeymoon i
bought a nirvana t-shirt i could have
just told you that and you would have
been like divorced
also by the way if you're in here in
your 20s right now and you're thinking
about getting a tattoo don't [ __ ] do
it your taste much like the person
you're here with now gonna change
like when i was in my 20s i wanted to
get a dave matthews band tattoo
yeah now as an adult i know i don't like
dave matthews band i just like being
drunk outside
[Applause]
that's not totally true i i
i mean i loved being drunk outside but i
just celebrated eight years sober which
is crazy
thanks a bunch
it's fine
it's funny sometimes i'll tell people
that they'll be like but you smoke weed
though right
and i'm like sober and they're like so
we
there's like a guy going a girl who's
like i'm a virgin i'm saving myself for
marriage and the dude's like so butt
stuff right
i didn't quit smoking weed though
because i had a problem with weed i quit
smoking weed because i got tired of
looking for my cell phone with the
flashlight on my cell phone
[Applause]
and it's crazy now because wheat is just
illegal in so many states around the
country you can just walk into a store
and buy weed over the counter it's nuts
like when i was a kid if you wanted to
buy weed you had to go to like a parking
lot or a substitute teacher
[Music]
yeah you had to be a guy there was a
protocol involved i'm worried about
these kids they're not gonna have life
skills
and now there's all these different
kinds of weed it's crazy there's like
indica sativa bubba kush northern lights
like it's nuts
like
when i was a kid there was only two
kinds of wheat there was dirt weed and
there was laced weed that's it
you're either not getting high or
getting way too [ __ ] high
like this is totally true first two
times i smoked weed nothing happened
third time i smoked weed it was pcp
i'm happy you enjoyed that miss cause i
did not
has anyone here ever been so high that
they watched cartoons for two hours and
then realized the television wasn't on
yeah turns out mitt romney not one of
the powerpuff girls
and here's the thing about when you
smoke angel dust it's gonna last a lot
longer than you were planning
and you're 15 and you've got a curfew
and you've got to be home real soon
[Music]
you know who's going to notice that
you're on pcp right away your mom she's
going to pick some [ __ ] up
and i don't know what gave me away the
fact that i wasn't wearing a t-shirt or
it was december in new york but she knew
and as soon as as soon as i walked
through the door my mom was like are you
high right now and i was like no i'm on
goldschlager
that's what i told her i just admitted
to a completely different crime
that's how i know i can never commit an
actual crime because if a cop was ever
like have you been drinking and driving
i'd be like no i murdered a drifter
[Applause]
and the craziest thing we do now is like
even though i'm sober i travel around
and it's crazy when i go to a state that
doesn't have legal weed because it's
always for like the most [ __ ]
excuses they're like what if the kids
get it they'll get cooler taste of music
they'll be fine
and people were like yeah but it's a
gateway drug and i'm like yeah to reggae
they'll be fine
like by a round of applause how many
people in here have smoked weed before
yeah my favorite of the people who are
high now because they raise their hand
present
present i'm here
[Music]
now by a round of applause how many
people have done heroin
yeah that's a pretty thin game
not one of us managed to shimmy through
it
that's why i'm
that's why i'm scared to have kids you
know i'm scared to have kids because i
don't want to pass these shitty irish
alcoholic jeans down to my children you
know like i don't want to just give them
these irish genes of mild depression and
varicose veins
[Music]
my biggest fear about having kids though
is i'm afraid that i'm gonna have a girl
uh and more so i'm afraid that i'm gonna
have a girl who looks like me
and
and i don't mean like the little girl
version of me i mean like me now
currently
[Applause]
because we've all seen that girl who
looks like her dad and she looks like a
little 40 year old plumber
and i don't want to do that [ __ ] to my
baby girl like picture me in pigtails in
a dress
yeah no one's [ __ ] that kid we're not
i do oh i didn't mean it like that
[Music]
i bet no one's [ __ ] that 35 year old
adult
35's weirder i think actually
what age do i want my daughter to get
[ __ ]
at yeah
17.
yeah
17 prom night he got a motel some
candles if you're [ __ ] my baby you're
spending some money
yeah
kevin from the baseball team strong
hands
maybe a catcher you know okay that one's
too far
look i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i've never talked about
this on stage before i never will again
so
[Applause]
i know 35's too old i don't want my
daughter walking around at 35 like one
day my prince will come and so will i
[Applause]
yeah we've all seen those people out in
the world running through a park yelling
at pigeons like get out of my way i have
a doctorate
[Applause]
speaking of the unfucked i got a good
story i could have here
right before everything shut down i went
to vegas to see a concert with all my
friends we went to go see elton john
play the farewell yellow brick road tour
unreal he played for three and a half
hours in that whole set there was one
song i didn't know when that song came
on i was like perfect time to get a
t-shirt
so i went down to get a t-shirt and they
had that [ __ ] roped off like space
mountain and i went to the wrong side
and i was i looked around no more there
was like [ __ ] i'm going underneath and
the second i go underneath i just hear
now
now like
like i'm a puppy [ __ ] on a carpet
and i just look up and there's this red
faced woman storm in towards me and i'm
like oh my god miss i'm so sorry i
didn't see you please go right ahead of
me she's like you goddamn right i'm
gonna go ahead of you jerk
my friend's like why is he a jerk he's
letting you go ahead of him and she's
like shut up you
[ __ ]
who gets that angry at an elton john
concert
i'll tell you a lady who hasn't come in
a hundred years
[Applause]
and in that moment i just burst out
laughing and she goes you know what go
[ __ ] yourself and i was like you know
what i did earlier today
that's probably why i'm being pretty
chill about this whole thing right now
maybe if you would have went [ __ ]
yourself we wouldn't be in this
situation right now
yeah we'd both be back in our seats
listening to tiny dancer
maybe we need to get you a pocket rocket
man of love
how did i get on that story i was
talking about my daughter no one would
[ __ ] okay here we go
she'd have way too hard of a life
growing up she'd show up for like her
first day of school and they'd be like
what do you want to be when you grow up
little girl and she'd be like princess
and they'd be like how about heating and
cooling technician
[Laughter]
women also just have it way harder than
dudes that's why i'm scared to have a
daughter because women have to deal with
way more [ __ ] [ __ ] than men do
like right now they're trying to ban
abortion again that shit's crazy to me
like that it's also never gonna happen
though mostly because the fact that no
millennials can afford to have kids none
of us
yeah you wanna know i know that every
millennial i know is still in their
parents phone family plan
yeah
like if you can't afford t-mobile you
can't afford a baby
like the only way millennials could
afford to have kids is if seven of us
shared one like an hbo max password
[Applause]
also women have to deal with the luxury
tax that's another [ __ ] thing women
have to deal with it's an extra seven to
ten percent tax on top of pads tampons
period [ __ ] it's [ __ ] i said that in
cleveland a couple months ago this dude
in the front row was like good and i was
like i hope a woman free bleeds all over
the front seat of your volvo
[Applause]
my diva cup crew over here
[Laughter]
i know my ex was afraid to have kids too
i know that because she said to me you
better not get me pregnant
i know
i know and she said it just like that
like we were two partners in a buddy cop
film who hadn't started trusting each
other yet
like she was just like you better not
get me pregnant i panicked i was like
well you better watch your back
yeah cause that's where i'm gonna put it
you guys get the point
[Applause]
i'm just kidding she would never let me
do that very sexually progressive just
hates a mess here's the thing
i don't want to get anyone pregnant i
like to have kids one day but those are
two totally different things like one of
them involves a birthing plan the other
the word oops like
yeah like when i have kids i want to use
words like excited and ecstatic i don't
want to make the same sounds as if i
just dropped some red wine on a carpet
just like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm so sorry
i could totally pay to have that taken
out
oh [ __ ] you guys don't know what that
show
[Applause]
yeah
yeah applauding was the right response
one in three women have had an abortion
so right now if you're here with like
your mom your sister and your aunt
you're wrong you're statistically making
one of them very uncomfortable
yeah i'm a feminist
i am
i am i'm a male feminist or not not male
feminist i got yelled at for that [ __ ]
the other day you're not supposed to
gender it i don't know why i'm smiling
while saying that
this is totally true one time i played
north carolina and i told a dude there
was a male feminist and i swear to god i
think he thought i meant transgender
he was just like so which bathroom do
you pee in and i was like we can't have
a conversation
just give me the [ __ ] slurping
also by the way i couldn't even get my
ex pregnant like she had an iud my sperm
is not stronger than science
and also for those of you men in here
who don't know what an iud is it's this
little tiny crossbow that your
girlfriend puts inside
yeah
that's exactly what it looks like it
looks like you're trying to hunt the
predator down there
or she doesn't put it in there a doctor
puts it in there if she put it in there
don't [ __ ] that lady
well if she got like a kmart do it at
home kind of kid you don't bang that
lady
you marry that lady she's thrifty
[Music]
i wish they made an iud for dudes i
really do i think that would be
incredible if they made an iud for men
but instead of stopping dudes from
getting pregnant it would just stop us
from sleeping with women we shouldn't
have kids with
yeah yeah we could call it something
like dignity
self-respect any of these names were
they better have a form of male birth
control by the time i have a son i'm not
letting that kid go free swinging that
dick in the streets no way
i know what kind of stock my kid came
from i wish my parents would have kept
my dick in a box so i was 28 years old
then at least i'd have like an
associate's degree
yeah now when i fill out paperwork i
have to check some college
i might as well write in all alcoholism
i also just had my first pregnancy scare
when i was super young i was way too
young i was 13 years old
yeah yeah i know i don't look like a guy
who was [ __ ] at 13. i look like a man
who's still saving himself for the lord
now
13. that's way too young you want how i
know it's too young i showed up on
rollerblades to find out about it
[Applause]
i got there and she was like you're
probably going to want to take those off
for this
and here's the crazy part dude when she
told me i swear to god i was like well
i'm definitely losing my allowance over
this [ __ ]
by the way
i was not planning on having sex at 13.
i didn't think i was like the man you
know what i mean what happened was my
parents were afraid i was already having
sex so my mom put condoms in my top
drawer and told me they could be used on
your wedding night but they're there if
you need them
i know cool ass mom
i told my girlfriend and she was like we
need them
i know i know and i was like thank you
mommy
[Applause]
my favorite part of that
my favorite part about that story too is
even the fact that i got to have sex it
means that there was a day where my mom
and my dad went to a cvs together walked
down that condom aisle had to look at
the 24-pack the 12-pack and the
three-pack and they had to ask
themselves how much do we believe in
this kid
they went with a three-pack appropriate
amount
[Applause]
they knew their baby boy but i was smart
i was smart
[Laughter]
i was smart i didn't want my parents to
know i was having sex so i did my own
little cvs condom recon mission right
and i go to that cvs and i walk down
that condo mile and there's literally
hundreds of condoms and i don't know
what to do i'm 13. i'm looking at all
these condos and i don't know what to
get all of a sudden i see the ones that
say magnums and i'm like magnums that
sounds cool
[Laughter]
so i pick up the magnums and i go to
take them up to the front but i get some
like other [ __ ] to camouflage them in
with you know what i mean like i pick up
my flintstones chewables peanut m ms
head up to the front and the lady starts
checking me out and then she gets the
magnum she looks at the magnums looks at
me and just goes yeah these aren't for
you
and she was right she was doing me a
solid i would have been tying the other
half off as a water balloon
they better have a [ __ ] iud for my
son that's all i'm saying
this is totally true i was on stage in
cleveland ohio a couple months ago and
while i was on stage talking about iuds
this lady just yells out from the back
of the room they don't know where mine
is
[Music]
and i was like what and she was like
yeah it's just kind of lost inside of me
and i was like
what are you doing here
and she was like the doctor said it'll
resurface
resurface what is it a [ __ ] russian
submarine
like with someone going down periscope
on your puss and just knock that thing
loose
do we need to go on a hunt for the red
october right now
that's not even the craziest part of
this story after the show i'm outside
i'm meeting the audience shaking hands
taking pictures totally different woman
comes up to me and she's like yeah iuds
they're crazy and i was like yeah and
she was like yeah every two weeks you
gotta get in there and you gotta check
for the strings and i was like what and
she was like yeah every two weeks you
gotta get in there and you gotta check
for the shrinks and i was like
i don't have to do anything
[Applause]
who raised these people in cleveland
my son's getting that [ __ ] iud
i got fears about having kids it's not
even just that like i'm also i don't
want to pass my shitty jeans down to my
kids i was born severely dyslexic and i
was born with a form of nerve damage in
my hands it caused my hands to shake
it's the reason why every instagram
videoman looks like a boomerang
it's also the reason why every
conversation i've ever had with the cops
is ended with yeah i'm still gonna have
to look in the trunk
i love my shaking hands now though of
all my disabilities shaking hands
definitely my favorite one as a kid i
was super embarrassed by it and made me
feel super weird now it's way more fun
and i'm not just talking about sexually
like think about the most boring thing
in your guy's life for example like
think about soup for example for you
guys soup very boring for me soup is
like an action movie
the people i'm sitting at the table with
are like i don't know if he's gonna make
it
[Laughter]
spoil alert i never make it
i'm so dyslexic too i'm super dyslexic
like i'm so dyslexic i'd say after the
show go ahead and follow me on twitter
if you hate spelling and grammar and
love puzzles
by the way the guy who came up with the
name and spelling for dyslexia huge
[ __ ]
like was there problem that can't read
or spell too well let's throw a silent y
in there
why because [ __ ] them it'll be funny for
the rest of us
as a dyslexic person texting is a
nightmare the only thing worse than
texting sexting
yeah because this is my job i travel for
a living i'm normally on the road like
40 weekends out of the year and it's
very hard to keep it spicy with the
woman when you're dating when she thinks
you're constantly trying to slide into
her virginia
but then talk to text came out that [ __ ]
was like a game changer for me but even
that would have its hiccups because i'd
be like ooh do you like that and siri
would be like yeah not so much
and every time i'm doing my talk to sex
like i said i'm always in some hotel
room and there's always a connecting
door and i'm always terrified on the
other side of that door is some sweet
family on vacation
and they hear me doing my talk to sex
and siri's always [ __ ] up the word so
you got to keep repeating yourself so
i'm just in there like panties panties
panties
like no why would i want to wear her
pastries [ __ ] off
we all have our things you know
[Applause]
i also have cerebral palsy i normally
don't talk about all these topics back
to back because then it sounds like i'm
trying to start myself a [ __ ]
foundation
like
that's the crazy thing about having all
my disabilities too like you couldn't
tell by looking at me like if i parked
in a handicapped spot at a store and you
saw me walk into a target you'd be like
i'm keying this motherfucker's car
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i would fall break a lot of bones and
[ __ ] like that because of my cp the
worst thing that the worst for me that
ever really happened when i was in sixth
grade i'd have both my legs put walking
casts to stretch my achilles tendons out
and to cheer me up my parents said we
were gonna take a trip now in your
logical 12 year old kid brand when you
hear trip where do you think we're going
exactly the hooters on staten island
i don't know you guys all did that at
once that was [ __ ] impressive
and here's the thing i'm 38 years old i
still wonder to this day sometimes who
pitched that idea my mom or my dad
because think about that was in that
doctor's office have my little fat hit
legs taped up to look like giant
cannolis
why don't i have to be out in that
waiting room like hey would it be funny
we take the boys see some boobies
i used that voice because i hope it was
my dad
and now my mom just like hey you know it
always cheers you up boobies
[Applause]
and as soon as we walked through the
door there's hooters my parents lied to
these waitresses and told them it's my
birthday do you guys know what they do
at hooters when it's your birthday they
make you stand on top of a plastic chair
and you air jerk off salt and pepper
shakers will they sing you happy
birthday
yeah like i had to do that [ __ ] in front
of my mom and dad
and i was 12. it wasn't like i didn't
know what this was
it was the year jurgen off showed up
and it showed up in a big way like the
two biggest things that you're in my
room were masturbation and oasis is
wonderwall
[Applause]
yeah it was a constant champagne
supernova
my dad's a man's man too my dad's a guy
my dad's a new york city firefighter and
a blue collar republican i'm a new york
city liberal and i do this for a living
i know it is funny sometimes i do think
to myself like is there any way you
could be a bigger disappointment to your
new york city firefighter father
then i think yeah gay terrorists
which by the way is what my dad calls a
yoga instructor so
very progressive man
my dad like i love my dad i love hanging
out with my dad the only problem is when
we hang out sometimes my dad's guy guy
friends come and they're all like the
types of guys who would like smack a
chick on the ass and be like hey what's
the matter with me what's the matter
with you that's a compliment you should
smile more you got a pretty face
we were at this yankees game a couple
summers ago and this dude was like hey
what do you do for a living pal how what
do you do you make something with your
hands what do you do
and i was like
oh i'm never going to tell you
and he was like come on what do you do
and my dad the judas saw me out
immediately he's like oh him he's a
comedian and they're like oh you
comedian tell us a joke funny guy come
on andrew dice clay tell us a joke
such i was like oh
no
and that guy got pissed he was like sure
whatever whatever your comedian your
comedian then he got up to get everyone
else beers but right before he leaves he
just leans in taps me and goes woof i'm
sweating like a jew in an audit here
yeah and they all start hysterical
laughing and then another one of them
taps me and goes now that's a comedian
no it's not that's just a racist with
good timing that's it
[Applause]
have you ever seen one of those dudes
who works out but does no cardio so he
just looks like someone ripped the arms
off a he-man and put him on a mr potato
head
that was that dude mustache and all and
he kept
he kept bragging
he kept bragging the whole game about
how he got laid the night before he was
like last night i totally did it with
this chick and then she left stuff in my
apartment so she could come back so we
could do it again
and i was like you sure wasn't because
she was like oh i gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here
the [ __ ] up part is though is guys
like that guy and guys like my dad make
the best dads mostly because of the fact
that their kids fear them
like that's not going to be the case for
my generation like none of our kids are
going to fear us mostly because the fact
that none of us are gonna work the kinds
of jobs you come home and beat your kids
from
like nobody comes home from a hard day
of graphic designing
and beats their kid
like you've never heard anyone be like
oh no look out dez photoshop crashed
[Applause]
my dad's idiot friend too is one of
those dudes who rocks a pop collar you
ever see one of those gentlemen
yeah by the way if you don't know what
the pop collar means basically what the
pop collar means is that guy is two bud
light limes away from telling you what
he really thinks about puerto ricans
he's racist
that's not a pop collar as much as it is
a reverse klu klux klan hoodie
and for some reason it's salmon
and this dude was like dude let me give
you a little bit of advice and i was
like oh i totally want advice from a man
who's dressed like a dog that just got
back from the vet what's up
and he was like when you date a chick
you gotta date a chick who loves sports
a chick who loves sports and his whole
logic was it's like being with one of
the guys
it's like being with one of the guys i
don't know me personally anytime i'm
[ __ ] anybody i want it to be like
none of the guys
like
like you're never going to hear me say
like oh wait do you mean my new
girlfriend jessica you'll totally love
her she'll totally remind you of greg
it's not gonna happen i did one time go
out on a date with a woman who loves
sports and it clearly went terrible
because i'm like this guy you know what
i mean
and about halfway through the date at
one point this lady just turned to me
and to my face she just went you know
they don't make men like they used to
anymore
yeah i know what in my face but the
[ __ ] up part is i totally had to agree
with her
because if they did i would have to hit
her for having an opinion on men
to be very clear that is a joke about
how i don't hit women
my dad's idiot friend found out i was
getting divorced at the time too and
he's like oh bro you're getting divorced
you better be careful because if you end
up getting divorced she could get half
your [ __ ] and i was like really that
actually sounds pretty good because
right now she already has all of my [ __ ]
i'd love to get some of that back
also by the way when you're broke and
you're going through a divorce it's not
like you have a lot of [ __ ] to split up
it's like oh do you want this half used
full of burnt cds or this d battery
yeah i let her keep the d battery
this way she can put in her vibrator and
go [ __ ] herself
[Applause]
that's my favorite one too
also by the way none of you ladies come
up to me at the show and be like hey
just so you know vibrators don't take d
batteries they take triple a's i know
that [ __ ]
also give yourself a [ __ ]
rechargeable you can come and save the
environment at the same time
you plug that little usb end in to the
end of your laptop while you watch porn
kill two clits with one stone
this is totally true before me and my
ex-wife got divorced we didn't have sex
for a whole year yeah i know we were
only married two years
right before we got divorced i told her
i was like hey i think we should move to
portland oregon and what she said to me
is oh you should go move to the woods
and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah so now much would have changed i
would have just been in the woods
then i met my new girlfriend we started
having sex lots of it
yeah
yeah we started having so much sex that
after the first week she had to get a
monostat
oh [ __ ] you guys do not make that noise
50 of the people on this planet have
vaginas and 99 of the time they get a
yeast infection is because of one of
those dirty dicks
so wash your goddamn dicks gentlemen
yeah yeah my situation was more of a
lube situation stay away from those blue
trojan condoms with the armaloo
here's the thing about monistat though
when you go to buy a lady a monoset they
duct tape that [ __ ] and they put a
security sensor on it yeah here's the
thing if somebody doesn't have the money
to buy that let them [ __ ] steal it
yeah like if my dick was on fire and you
sold fire extinguishers and i didn't
have 20 bucks to give you and you
wouldn't let me use it you're a piece of
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you cvs that's what i'm trying
to say with that joke
[Applause]
my whole goal in comedy my whole goal in
comedy is i just want to get famous
enough one day where i could start my
own foundation we're outside of every
cvs i'm gonna have like my own kind of
red box situation but instead of movies
it's just gonna be filled with monosat
and cranberry pills
yeah and all that shit's gonna be free
it's gonna be called the box box
yeah we're not gonna have pads in it
though because then every 28 days we
still have to call it the red box
here's the other thing about manusat i
know you weren't expecting this much
monastery stuff to come out of a man in
a canadian tuxedo but buckle up here we
go
there's two different one-day mono sets
why the [ __ ] are there two one-day mono
sets it's in the name one that should be
it there's an ovule and there's a
pre-loaded stick i [ __ ] up i bought
the wrong one and then i brought it home
and i showed it to my girlfriend at the
time and she was like oh i can't use
this cause if i use it it'll burn like
the wrath of vala
yeah direct quote she's very funny
and i was like no problem i'm a man i'll
bring the [ __ ] back i don't give a [ __ ]
but i forgot the bag and the receipt at
home and as soon as i walked through the
door of that cvs what do you think
happens yeah that [ __ ] security
sensor went off and i pulled a monistat
out of my pocket and the security
security guard looked at me like i just
opened up a vest of dynamite he just
looked down on the floor and was like do
whatever the [ __ ] you got to do and get
out of here
so i went and got pre-loaded stick and i
took sick and alveol up to the counter
and i said to the lady i need to
exchange this for this and she goes oh
[ __ ] yeah no problem she goes i just
need your receipt and i go oh my god i
left it at home in the bag and she goes
oh without a receipt i can't help you
cbs policy [ __ ] cvs
and i panicked i did the only thing i
could think to do and i just leaned over
the counter i put my hand on this lady's
hand i said lady look i know you got a
heart but you also got a [ __ ] so let's
make this thing happen
yeah she let me do it i exchanged stick
for avial there was a dollar price
difference she put it on a gift card for
me and i bought some rolos came home a
hero
all right thanks a lot guys if you're
enjoying virus
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
you